how much fun is it being here oh it's so
fun I keep saying this but this is one
of my favorite award shows so it is to
be back with the the Dance Moms cast cuz
we've been gone for two years from the
show and we're back and we're kind of
bald seed seed it together so that makes
the show a lot more fun because you're
with a big group so I'm excited that
that we're all kind of together tonight
two years I mean that's crazy how much
did you guys stay in touch during that
time not very much it was pretty awkward
I to be honest like I left this show
very abruptly and we didn't we didn't
really have a proper goodbye it was just
we left it very weird and so anytime I
would see them we would say hi but it
would be it wasn't how it used to be and
then I went back to the show we've kind
of rekindled that friendship so it
should be fun my never laughs I think
that we can all expect a totally
different show right it's best season so
different I think it's very different
than from what fans are expecting so I
hope you guys like it I personally think
it's the best season yet I really do I
think it's gonna be amazing I think
people are really gonna get behind it
Cheryl Burke's amazing she's fabulous
the girls all kind of grow up tone and
vibe of the show are very I think it's
much more lighthearted and driven
towards dance what which is what the
show is about and should have always
been driven towards but there's speed
bumps along the way when you look back
at that time with Abby Lee Miller are
you traumatized from it what do you
learn from the drama sighs I'm grateful
for the experience only because I'm a
huge believer that everything happens
for a reason so I think I was meant to
have that good and bad experience and
kind of learn and grow from and it
definitely gave me thick skin which is
crucial for this industry industry um so
yeah were you guys surprised about the
prison sentence no why not well I've
known Abby a very long time so I can't
say I was really surprised I saw she she
ate some mac and cheese on her way in
president watched I wouldn't give her
the ratings you guys were so excited to
watch you I'm if you could describe the
new season in a couple words like how
would you different light-hearted and
coming home
[Music]
you